the UK's wind power industry is feeling
squeezed with soaring costs and limited
tax incentives it was hoping the budget
would provide a comprehensive lift but
that didn't happen
now major Wind Farm developer orstead is
questioning whether horns E3 its largest
project yet can even go ahead we were
really hoping that we would see a
response to what we and other project
owners have been looking for from the
chancellor and he's focused his efforts
on other areas
it's a real disappointment it certainly
makes it challenging we've been very
clear that this is a project that brings
fantastic jobs through construction and
through Decades of operations and we
really want to make sure we can realize
that but the chancellor is certainly not
made that easier it is a stark warning
from a critical industry player horns E3
here's the planned location about 75
miles off the Norfolk Coast is due to
begin production in 2026 if it goes
ahead the 8 billion pound project would
be the biggest wind farm in the world
with around 230 wind turbines generating
enough electricity to power more than 3
million homes projects like this are
crucial to the government's Ambitions to
deliver a five-fold increase in offshore
wind power by the end of the decade
making the problem worse Fierce
competition from America and Europe both
agreeing to substantial subsidy packages
in the global race to become a clean
energy superpower we're one of the
largest investors in UK infrastructure
generating jobs right across the country
but I think we can't really take that
position for granted uh it's not just us
now Leading The Way with minimal
competition from abroad other countries
are really hot on our heels the
government is due to set out further
measures to incentivize investment in
the nation's renewable Industries
Industries now looking for reassurance
that the UK after leading on wind for so
long isn't about to start falling behind
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News